kubernetes has gained immense popularity
for its ability to enable businesses to
run and manage apps at scale and gke is
the most scalable and fully automated
kubernetes service
Google created kubernetes and Google
kubernetes engine was the first managed
kubernetes product on the market in
2015. years ahead of other Cloud
providers we've spent that time making
it easier to use and harder to make
mistakes gke is with you every step of
the way supporting you all the way from
your humble beginnings as you start with
one line cluster creation all the way to
more than 15
000 nodes no matter how much you grow
gke perfectly scales to meet your needs
gke continues to be the most scalable
and fully automated kubernetes service
kubernetes makes it easier to
orchestrate your containers but there's
still a lot that goes into getting it
right
to be production ready you'll need to
handle many different tasks like
monitoring scaling upgrading and
securing your clusters back I do a lot
of overhead when you want your team to
keep their focus on developing your
application so you might be looking for
a managed solution using gke means
having Google Engineers take care of
implementing all of the recommended
practices for kubernetes so your
developers can focus on building the
applications that run on top of
kubernetes gke autopilot the default and
recommended way to run containers on gke
takes this further than any prior
kubernetes offering with built-in
security best practices and automated
worker node management this makes it
much easier to get started with
kubernetes allowing your team to build
and deploy faster you still have access
to pods services deployments and all the
other kubernetes resources that you'd
expect from the kubernetes API but
without the hassle and complexity that
comes from less robust offerings gke
autopilot is still fully kubernetes with
Cube control but you eliminate the need
to manage nodes or capacity so you get
to focus on your workloads while gke
handles your infrastructure before
releasing kubernetes in 2015 Google had
already been using containers internally
for over 10 years our experience running
containers at scale is why we can offer
a workload level SLA for gke autopilot
gke shares the responsibility for
keeping your pods up and running with
our pod level SLA a truly groundbreaking
commitment to your success and did we
mention scale from Gmail to YouTube to
search everything at Google runs in
containers gke is the most scalable
kubernetes service in the world and
extremely cost effective you request the
resources and we handle the bin packing
for you eliminating the ongoing burden
of optimizing cluster resource
utilization
like Google optimize your clusters for
you allowing you to focus on your
workloads saving you time and money
the Simplicity is real just change a
single line of yaml in your pod spec and
you have the control over the hardware
that gets provisioned just in time when
you go to deploy your workload this
could be choosing between arm spot
pricing CPU optimized Hardware memory
optimized hardware and even running on
Nvidia gpus all with just a single line
of code
you get a built-in security posture
scalability Simplicity and more without
giving up the ability to run Daemon sets
or stateful applications or almost
anything else your team can put into a
container Google and kubernetes are the
perfect match
gke is everything you love about
kubernetes with Google behind you every
step of the way we're excited to see
what you build on gke
[Music]
oh